we know all about the power struggle
between the US and China but this week
we saw it play out on the San Diego
coastline
the U.S president along with the UK and
Australian Prime Ministers gathered
before a strategically placed submarine
as they announced that orcas Pact
that's essentially a deal to provide
Australia with nuclear-powered
submarines to patrol the Pacific Ocean
it's an honor honor to be here to
welcome prime minister Albanese and
prime minister sunac and the last 18
months the challenges we Face have only
grown Russia's illegal invasion of
Ukraine China's growing assertiveness
the destabilizing behavior of Iran and
North Korea forging this new partnership
we're showing again how democracies can
deliver we are bound above all
by our belief in a world where the
sovereignty of every nation is respected
they weren't explicit in saying this is
all about concerns over China but
there's no question that is what this is
about and china hit back quickly Beijing
accusing the U.S the UK and Australia of
embarking on a path of error and danger
I'm Sally Lockwood infernil Patterson
and this is the Sky News Daily
it's almost as though conflict with
China not cold conflict but hot conflict
has been baked in as something that's
now inevitable both sides have got to a
stage where they can't seem to
reasonably de-escalate even relatively
small things that that's pretty worrying
that's Mark Stone and Helen and Smith
our U.S and Asia correspondents we got
together on a video call to discuss this
growing tension and distrust between the
two superpowers are you can I just ask
are you in your apartment
I used to live in that very block wow
just above Jenny Lewis also really close
to Jenny Lewis it's really the only
place that you can buy things like
Marmite and peanut butter so
Mark Conan it's great to have you with
us Mark let's just begin with you
explaining if you can exactly what's
been announced in San Diego and why it's
so significant it's all about submarines
Sally at least in in the short term and
I say short term because we're still
talking a very long time and it is about
using British technology and American
Technology to help Australia replace
their their submarine Fleet in Practical
terms that's what it's about the
Australian submarine Fleet uh is coming
to the end of its life it needs a new
one and a deal has been done in which
the Americans in the medium term will
sell some existing submarines to the
Australians but in the longer term we're
talking 2030s 2040s the Brits and the
Americans will build submarines for the
Australians and with the Australians
that is in Practical terms what it's
about what it's really about in one word
is China that is a neat link over to you
helenan explain to us if you can how
China's responded to this submarine Pact
and the sort of rhetoric we've been
hearing out of California
yeah well I mean very broadly the
Chinese have responded with pretty
predictable anger frustration
indignation a lot of the phrases we've
had have been sort of right out of a
pretty familiar Playbook so a
spokesperson from the foreign Ministry
described it as a typical Cold War
mentality that the countries are quote
traveling down a dangerous and wrong
path you know they say that it's
encouraging an arms race and broadly
they're you know deeply deeply unhappy
about it I think it touches on a few
things for China I mean firstly it
really doesn't like kind of shows of
unity from its quote-unquote enemies if
you like in a kind of public the photo
shoots that very Global display of kind
of unity against them they find that
very provocative but really sort of most
importantly the reason China hates this
so very much is really the island of
Taiwan and it comes everything in the
region really comes back to that when it
comes to kind of defense and security
and whatnot fundamentally the
self-governing island of Taiwan that
China sees as its own it has repeatedly
said the current leadership that it
reserves the right to take that Island
by force and frankly if and when it does
make such a move the last thing it wants
is a strong defense pact in that region
that would prevent it taking the action
at once I think it's the first point you
made um Helena is really interesting
about the show I was actually quite
surprised at the extent to which the
Brits the Americans and the Australians
decided to make a show of this to such
an extent three world leaders standing
in San Diego a submarine behind them U.S
Marines all around you know they could
quite easily have just got their defense
ministers to make an announcement and
they could have done something very
low-key it would have been just a
defense deal some sort of a you know a
contract that had been done between
these two countries but instead they
decided to go all out and have this
massive show and they absolutely knew
that the Chinese response would be very
angry is that you know interpreted as
inflammatory in China
yeah it's deeply inflammatory in terms
of how the Chinese perceive it
absolutely and the reason that it is is
I think it really touches on this
perception that the Chinese have about
what it calls sort of the policy of
containment and this is a word that has
just dominated all of the conversation
when it comes to China versus the West
in particularly in recent months because
the Chinese you know hold this
fundamental belief and it really
pervades everything that they do and say
that the US LED Alliance of the West if
you like fundamentally Western countries
have a problem in principle with China
in ascendancy that it has a problem in
principle with China growing and
developing and and that frankly it will
do everything it can to stop that and
that's why these very public shows upset
China so much because they see it as
part of a very self-conscious attempt to
circumvent China's growth and China's
ascendancy and China's power and
crucially circumvent it from taking what
it sees as it sort of rightful place at
the center of global Affairs but Joe
Biden's calls it is is competition not
confrontation so he what he would say is
all we want uh is is healthy competition
between two great superpowers and we do
not want confrontation and I think you
know at the outset it is worth saying
that I don't think there is any desire
by either Nation for confrontation they
don't want confrontation at least not at
the moment
um but but the Optics have changed that
sort of kind of irritating word we use
in the media the Optics have changed and
the rhetoric has changed significantly
on both sides and I think what's what's
happened in the last 10 years suddenly
China is doing what the West has been
doing for years I mean the West has been
interfering in other nations business
and trying to mold a world order that
they would see as being the right world
order a western world order a democratic
World Order they've been doing that for
years and years and years suddenly
there's a new player on the pitch and
it's China and it's doing it naturally
to its own world order as it sees it but
for years and years historians have been
waiting for that moment where the rise
of China is suddenly going to come and I
think that time has now come and
America's like oh you know we've got to
do something about this we're no longer
the only player in town
and Helena just explained to us from a
Beijing perspective you know with
President xi's third term in office now
underway are we seeing a hardening of
Chinese rhetoric towards the U.S
well that's a really really interesting
question because let's be clear a very
key difference between China and the US
is that China guards its words extremely
carefully so very small moves in
rhetoric can mean a very great deal in
China in the way that they don't in
America things don't get said by
accident here look China has always been
much more
of the West right it has been skeptical
of the West for centuries
um and so its narrative and its rhetoric
towards the US have always been colder
they've always been harder but there has
been notable kind of uh ramping UPS you
know just small signs just for instance
last week president Xi Jinping himself
spoke about the containment policy led
by the United States and that's a really
important thing because normally he
would have left that to his more Junior
ministers to really stick the boot in
like that the fact he chose to say it
out loud and be quoted on it was
significant you know the Chinese are
hardening their line and I just think
it's really interesting talking you know
picking up what Mark said about the
posturing my goodness the posturing
matters here so much and it matters for
slightly different reasons than in the
US of course it doesn't have a you know
Chinese Communist party does not have an
opposition party with which to answer to
it does not have a voting public that
might boot out in the next election but
face saving matters so much here and it
is a deeply patriotic Place China right
not just the the government but the
people and this kind of phenomenal
economic rise that China has seen this
new world order that it is able to set
its new place in the world people are
really proud of it and the government is
really proud of it and that sense that
it would be challenged and contained is
really offensive and that explains a lot
of why I think dialing down from this
very difficult position we're in right
now is going to be very difficult on
both sides Mark I can see you nodding is
there anything you want to add to that
well just the the first point that her
lands said I completely agree with that
nothing is ever said by a mistake in
China and the opposite is often the case
in America because because it is a
democracy because you've got so many
different people chiming in and so
things are said that that might be not
sort of tow the the administration the
U.S Administration line and you know
America is seen around the world now as
being less reliable if you talk to
countries in the Middle East of Saudi
Arabia Israel to a certain extent
um the gulf Arab countries they no
longer see America as a reliable partner
because they see America as retreating
because they see the the flip-flop
politics of America you've got Biden one
minute and then Trump the next minute we
could have Trump back again
um and and the foreign policy under
modern American Republican party and
Democratic party it is not uniforming
because of all that they cannot rely on
America and so they're looking elsewhere
and they're looking for a more reliable
partner China's politics never changes
right so if you want something that's
more reliable that's that's going to be
uniform then it's China and it was
absolutely fascinating to see the Saudi
leaders and the um Iranian leaders pop
up in Beijing to announce a new peace
pact I mean no one expected that I mean
it was an amazing moment where suddenly
the Chinese had managed to forge this
new alliance that was very significant
is China is a very self-consciously
selling that reliability and that kind
of lack of flip-flopping and that sort
of steadfastness not just because it
thinks it will Advantage it but because
it truly believes that it is a better
way to run a country and in light of
that just a quick thought from you both
if I may on the fact that we are now
seeing this great power struggle between
the US and China could we now
potentially be seeing the two Nations
entering a new Cold War Mark I think
we're already pretty much there I I find
I'm sort of constantly surprised at the
extent to which it's almost as though
conflict with China not cold conflict
but hot conflict has been baked in as
something that's now inevitable down the
line
um I mean you turn on the cable news
channels here and the straps at the
bottom of the screen are you know the
threat of China it permeates everything
the Spy balloons you know it was only a
month ago that we thought maybe that
Anthony blinken was going to go to
Beijing that would have been a huge
moment he'd have met Xi Jinping and yet
it was all canceled so yeah I think we
are in in a period of entering a a very
tricky moment for let's be absolutely
clear the most important geopolitical
relationship in the world because it is
China America you know to add to that I
think it's you know I think we are
already there mark mentioned the Spy
balloon incident and I think that's a
really really interesting one because I
think what that did is it really proved
really the inability of both sides to
resolve even the most trivial of matters
right fundamentally both countries know
they're spying on each other and one
balloon kind of floating over is not
really that big a deal but neither side
could possibly find a way to de-escalate
that situation right and as a as a
consequence we lost the blink and visit
as Mark said and things have really
spiraled since and and because both
sides have got to a stage where they
can't seem to reasonably de-escalate
even relatively small things that that's
pretty worrying in terms of how that
cold war is and how it has the potential
to develop and I really think we're at a
stage now where you know a misstep from
one side or the other and things could
get really really serious
there was a an incident that happened
all the way back in 2001 uh where a
American spy plane was kind of in the in
the kind of region of China and it
actually had a collision with a Chinese
plane right a Chinese pilot died the
Americans had to bail out and were were
stuck on the island of Hainan and China
for a while in the end the regimes were
able to resolve it the Americans were
sent home there was sort of a sort of
vague statement where both sides were
able to save face and can you imagine
that happening now in in the current
climate we live in like the kind of the
Chinese social media nationalists the
Republican Party being what it is it's
kind of really impossible to imagine
which is scary
okay so Mark Helena we've talked a lot
about the rising tensions between the US
and China but Mark How likely is this to
spill over into actual open conflict a
hot War rather than a cold one if you
like well I go back to the point I made
earlier is that they neither side wants
it um it's not in their interests
because it would be a World War like
like nothing we've ever seen before but
that doesn't mean that they can't stop
it from happening there's another really
interesting uh story it was just a
couple of days after the January 6th
protests here in in Washington in 2021
there was a phone call between General
Mark milley the top U.S general here and
General Lee his Chinese counterpart
Millie had to pick up the phone and call
his Chinese counterpart to tell him that
the Americans were not about to bomb
China because the Chinese had picked up
some
incorrect intelligence from the
Americans from Trump that something was
about to happen it was all incorrect but
there was a line of communication that
existed where the top American General
could pick up the phone speak to his
Chinese counterpart and say look relax
this isn't going to happen that line is
I don't think it's in place at the
moment I don't know if if you've got any
more on that Helena but I don't it's
it's not good the comms are not good
what an anecdote what a story so so do
you think from from that moment on
January 6th in 2021 Communications the
the back channels the Diplomatic
conversations have deteriorated between
China and America Helena yeah I think
the other thing that plays into that
Communication channel is you know the
reality of what's Happening Here is that
President XI jinping's regime is
increasingly a regime of loyalists and
allies and for one of the better word
cronies than it is of technocrats and
professionals so a lot of the
relationships that previously existed
these people maybe aren't in those jobs
anymore and we've got sort of
nationalists and party Loyalists and and
she allies in some of these top
positions and just aren't in a very
practical sense some of those kind of
channels have kind of closed you know
quite aside from whether they've um
closed off the back of you know upsets
and and whatnot so yeah I think it's a
significantly more difficult
atmosphere and a final thought from you
both in light of the growing tensions
and distrust that we've discussed
between the two countries what hope is
there do you think of any de-escalation
or diplomatic breakthrough Mark to you
first
well given that we were only a few weeks
ago talking about the visit of Anthony
blink in the U.S Secretary of State to
China where he was due to meet the
Chinese president
um and and we it's all Fallen apart very
very quickly I mean an optimist would
say surely they can build it back up
again uh to the extent that that visit
can be back on and you know
hopefully but things are not looking
good and and the the language is Stark
within America China's the new bogeyman
China is the Russia or the Soviet Union
of the Cold War and and it's hard to row
back from that especially as we're
getting into an election season in
America uh where this sort of thing
plays well with Republican candidates
for sure yeah it's look it's absolutely
true that the Chinese don't want to war
they don't want to war you know for all
the kind of human reasons the financial
reasons but also remember the pla the
people's Liberation Army which is the
sort of the army here in China they've
actually never fought a war you know
officially the pla have never fought a
war so there are a lot of questions
about to what degree the military here
would even be ready or capable to fight
a war like that that is definitely a
thing that plays into their minds in the
back you know I think the other thing
here that if you wanted to be an
optimist you could call on is I do think
that Xi Jinping
cares a lot about his International
reputation he cares a lot about
and we saw that in the last year when
Biden and she sat down at the G20 in
Bali and both of them said you know we
have responsibilities as the leaders of
these superpowers to fix our
relationship we have a responsibility to
not let it spiral because many other
countries around the world rely on us
having a stable relationship so
an optimist might say it's not beyond
the Realms of possibility that seeking
to heal some of this damage might be a
kind of a diplomatic play he would want
to make but look as Mark said there are
just the unpredictability of them and
this seeming inability to resolve even
small things you know just small
incidences have ways of allowing things
to spiral further and sadly I think it's
likely to continue to be as bad if not a
bit worse for some time to come I think
well Hernan it's been great to speak to
you both thank you so much thanks thank
you
why thanks to Helena and Mark and to you
for listening to the Sky News Daily with
me Sally Lockwood this episode was
produced by Rosie Gillett with Alex Eden
the editor is Paul stanworth